but then like if I'm gonna do like
specific oh you're gonna get weird yeah
then I'll do private browsing what are
your Search keywords for for VPN or for
porn porn VPN I don't
I don't do Search keywords
[Music]
I I personally really thought this story
was amazing because I learned a lot of
new [ __ ] and now you're gonna learn the
same new [ __ ] oh okay I love education
I'll talk about three things one of them
is called price tourism
I didn't know what that was either I
made the same face the other one is e
Invasion e invasion is another thing and
the third thing is how those integrate
with Argentina that's pretty [ __ ]
amazing all right dude I'm ready for
this [ __ ] I'm not lost maybe Nick is
but I'm done oh I totally got it dude
listen to this so it all has to do with
Nintendo switch all right when people
make a game and they put the game for
sale on Nintendo switch let's say you
want to sell your game for 24 right that
price is going to be adjusted for
different countries and the current
economy state they're in makes sense
when that goes to Argentina the price is
going to fluctuate over there it's gonna
cost a dollar fifty because they're
totally in the [ __ ] right so what
people do and this is a price tourism
thing they are gonna start an account
that's based in Argentina so that they
can buy the game for a dollar fifty and
then but they're really just in America
playing it they you can't resell digital
games that's right that oh so it's
digital so it's kind of like a VPN kind
of thing exactly so what e invasion is
is that happens with a ton of different
online products is people will go to the
certain countries that are having the
worst economic crisis and they will just
buy things that are available there that
are also available here but at the price
of the tanked economy just capitalize on
yeah smart yeah so that's something that
a lot of people started to realize was
happening on Nintendo switch in
particular because people would release
games and they would go oh my God like I
just released my game and I have like
hundreds of pre-orders already and then
they'll see that it's all Argentina and
they'll go [ __ ] because that's only a
dollar fifty per game so they're always
going no what the hell like all these
people are doing that thing and uh for
the for the first time somebody was able
to observe that it actually backfired in
a good way for them
the game developer yeah the game
developer so the price just before so
this guy made a game called uh let's
build a zoo it's a little cute game it's
really nice oh cool so they uh they
released that and he had the same thing
happen where he goes oh no price tours
and they [ __ ] hijacked my thing and
there's all these purchases for a dollar
fifty and he's like I'm [ __ ] that's it
and so what happened though is because
it's in Argentina the way that Nintendo
in particular tallies up all of their
sales for games they include Argentina
as being part of the of America because
it'll be like all the Americas Oh north
and south so on the algorithm that's
still American Sales and so what that
means is the algorithm is going to look
at it and go oh a lot of people are
buying this game in a place where it's
priced 24 that means America is one of
the full price countries that the
economy is at a normal level and because
of that it's gonna go front page so it's
like most sold or top seller right now
or something like that even though he's
really only made like 16 even though the
dollar dollar amount is not high the
priority for where people will see this
game it's going to look like the reviews
are in it's a hot game it's a hot game
so what happened in that case is because
buying it then every other country in
the world it's going to read as hey this
is what American kids are buying and
it'll be priced out there exactly and
then it's going to be a top shelf game
yeah all right yeah so that happened to
this game and because of that his sales
actually the game actually blew up in
popularity over something that's
initially supposed to ruin your sales
did you buy the game no I don't I don't
play kids games you don't play I do I do
play kids are people satisfied people
love the games oh so the really good
thing about it is that you know because
what's supposed to be a disaster thanks
to price tourism and e-invasion in just
the right way on just the right platform
on an algorithm that's exclusive to
Nintendo not everything reads sales that
way but Nintendo specifically does
America's as a whole
what else is cheap in Argentina
pretty much everything I'm surprised
they don't adjust prices though because
like they do it with clothes and like
Apple products like if you go to a a
country where the Dollar's strong it's
gonna be that you're gonna end up paying
the same amount
they just adjust it how much is a this
in an Argentina you think well 20 bucks
I assume for like phones they probably
adjust well I think I think that might
be a different category of stuff like
for example the Nintendo switch itself I
don't think you can get for like 10
bucks in Argentina there might still be
a normal transition like uh premium on
it yeah because same thing even with
like ps5s that aren't available here you
can get them in other countries but it's
not that much for a thousand dollars but
comparing something that's digital
exactly yeah exactly absolutely it's a
digital thing so and it's uh you can't
resell it so you're not gonna be able to
scalp that market so they they price it
accordingly because a lot of the time
too uh Publishers will go you know what
I don't want to sell it for a dollar
fifty that's too cheap I'm gonna sell it
for nine dollars or whatever but in an
economy like Argentina you'll get zero
sales like nobody's gonna buy that [ __ ]
they're not trying to buy [ __ ] games
right now
50 then you have a better chance plus
like they didn't want to start raising
the price once they see it being
hijacked because they don't want to
screw over kids that are actually buying
it for a dollar
yeah I remember too um correct me if I'm
wrong right but I think when I got the
Nintendo switch a few years ago too
somebody was advising that I like sign
up for a Nintendo account or like turned
it on to like the Japanese setting
versus the American because if you open
up the Japanese setting on the game like
you're playing in Japan you get access
to like all the games like a bunch of
stuff that you don't even necessarily
get access to obviously all you got to
be down for is like audio and subtitles
like through the Nintendo shop yeah
because the store will adjust to what's
available in your region so if you're
like a VPN again like what's on Netflix
same thing like you can buy certain
games that aren't released here or are
not going to be released yet
but it'll be in Japanese yeah I was
gonna say it's going to be in Japanese
it's going to be exactly Japanese I
think that's so dumb that they do that
like I think they should just if it's on
Netflix or like whatever the switch
thing it should just be available to
everybody
like why did they make us go through
getting a VPN oh like you should be able
to toggle what region on your own yeah
and then like if you want a Japanese
game dude just put you know click Japan
and then go go for but we have to go
through this whole long process of don't
they do that to make more money like to
base off a different territory I think
it's licensing for Netflix it's
licensing I don't know about with
Nintendo because I don't play games
because I'm a grown man yeah um oh I'm
sorry I didn't know I feel like you're
taking shots at me give me time man I
don't grow out of it uh but yeah for
like Netflix
um even let's say Disney plus Disney
plus has bought a lot of um like
exclusive rights to Korean dramas but
they only show them in Asia until
they're all aired then they'll release
them for the rest of the world but if
you have a VPN you can you can like
pretend that you're in Korea or Japan
and you can watch those things uh
Netflix I don't know if you guys been on
Netflix in Asia they have like literally
everything but then as soon as you cross
over it's like if they need to cut like
30 40 yeah I've heard that from Canadian
Netflix and also the UK Netflix yeah
you're telling me actually got a VPN no
well Netflix actually does a really
great job of recognizing vpns as well so
so when it when it algorithm
algorithmically like checks a proxy
setting or something like that it'll be
like oh you can't stream right now
because there's some sort of proxy going
on or whatever like so if you're in the
actual country you got full access
because you're for real in that spot but
if you're using a VPN on Netflix
oftentimes again correct me if I'm wrong
if anybody has better experience but
I've tried to VPN into like a number of
different countries to Netflix and it'll
actually be able to see that I'm like
using a VPN there why are they so [ __ ]
up like yeah that's annoying dude I've
learned that not all vpns are created
equal which one's the best yeah so hold
on which one are you which one are you
sponsored by for that yeah
so there's one I don't want to divulge
it too much because I I don't like
burning my uh Avenues of fun all right
though you gotta tell it I'll just give
hints okay so
um
fed or federal it's a shipping thing
okay a VPN oh God yeah yeah I got that
that one that one works I know I use
that one yeah that one works really well
what don't worry about it
that one works really well he's like
yeah FedEx VPN and what's cool is is
that when you bring it up they just have
an on off switch which makes because
when when you have it on and you forget
um you know because I think other vpns
you have to go into the settings and
like switch stuff out this one is just
the app and you turn it on or off and
what's great about it and because when
you when you have it on and then your
other your other apps won't work
properly you can't airdrop you can't you
know recognize certain things absolutely
yeah so this makes it super simple you
just so I just put it right next to the
Disney Plus app
whenever I watch Disney plus I just you
know make sure to hit that is um are
like streaming services the only thing
you use your VPN for you got other
little he's not gonna say porn yeah no
no porn porn I I'm I don't know I gotta
be honest with porn like I feel like
everyone kind of watches it so if
someone like someone being the
government snatched my computer and then
like oh he watches this porn like you
know it's all normal stuff but then like
if I'm gonna do like specific thick oh
you're gonna get weird yeah then I'll do
private browsing yeah but other than
that like I don't use VPN because you
know why people what are your Search
keywords for for VPN or for porn porn
VPN
daily
no I've got sites well like no give us a
hint I just go to categories oh and what
are some wild cat or some zany some like
crazy ones like uh what like zany that's
a good word Korean Filipino
are you just talking about this table
yeah
that's nice like three videos come up
but yeah they're fired
there's nothing wrong with it just turns
your self webcam on [ __ ]
[Music]